[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
it's my turn to uh
share more about my spiritual journey it
being the one year anniversary
or give or take of each of us
sharing about our spiritual journeys
from yeah
up up into bean in our early four
of course i'm about to hit mid-40s yeah
yeah you are i think when you hit 44
that's mid
let's just call it 45 but of course i
assume you listened to rhett's last week
if you didn't
uh i encourage you to do that so
last week i again i appreciate you
opening up and
processing how things are going for you
uh
at the point of recording this that
one's not even out yet so
i mean i'm anticipating lots of response
and conversations so thanks for being a
part of that
using hashtag earbiscuits um
yeah so now it's my turn to be on the
hot seat uh
definitely feeling nerves associated
with this because i mean un like you
said last week unlike
most podcasts we put we put a lot more
forethought into this and like either
i mean this is a this is a a rewarding
process
it's been i mean it's been challenging
for me to pull together what i wanted to
say we've talked about it some i've
you know had conversations with christie
as well and um
so if you're if
if if you want to go to some emotional
places and explore
uh my spiritual journey as it stands
over this past year
buckle up but um if you just want to
hear me
uh talk about my cat well i'll just do
that next week
so you can just wait until next week but
if i warn you if you're a cat lover
uh you might not want to listen to that
one either i don't know i don't know
we'll see
well no i'm sure they will but that one
you know
it'll get a little lighter but i'd we'll
see we'll see where this one goes well
i and before you get started you know i
think it's um
you know it's significant that we get
sort of
keyed up before we talk about these
things and
um i think there's we're not going to
really
we're not going to spend any time really
talking about that or exploring that but
i do think that
uh it is in the least
or in part related to
just how um
big of a part of our lives all of this
stuff was
and you know and so and how significant
it was and i think if you're
a christian or a former christian
or somewhere in between um
you can probably relate to that this
being the
most important thing in your
life and so when you get really
open and vulnerable vulnerable about it
it can stir some some things in ways
that
talking about your cat might not
[Laughter]
i wouldn't call it my cat but okay wait
until next week for that but
uh yeah i've i've i've journaled down
the things that i want to share
and uh so let's let's just get into it
like i said a year ago or so i shared my
story of spiritual deconstruction from
an evangelical christian to
a hopeful agnostic is what is what i
called it at the time i don't
i don't really refer to that label a lot
you know i'd
uh but that's i and i still think that
applies
um in that story cover my entire life
you know i'd there were snapshots from
uh age 10 and on right but
today i'm only covering the last year so
it's uh
it's it's it's a different thing i mean
it's been a crazy year and it's been a
tough one for
everybody on this planet of course
to varying degrees but
it's been a crazy year and over this
past year i was blindsided by a number
of
difficult challenges that i would have
as an evangelical christian have labeled
as tests of faith meaning
something happens in your life and your
response to it reveals
what you truly and deeply believe
um i i didn't think of the things that
i'm going to share today
in that way as they were happening and i
think that's that's kind of part of
what i want to share and how i did
process those things
but you know in in in kind of a compare
and contrast i realized that's
that's how my former self would see the
things i went through as test of faith
to put it even more specifically in the
past
as a christian i shuddered
at the thought of facing suffering
facing
fear and facing loss
without the peace that accompanied a
very specific belief about jesus
um i think that's something that a lot
of people can relate to
i know for for me when you
when you think about the potential of
not having
god in your life in the same way or not
having that relationship with jesus in
the way that you
that you that you did in the past you
you're like even in transition i know
you talked to me a lot about this
as we were sort of transitioning there
was this
fear of like is something horrible going
to happen and i won't be able to make it
through
because uh yeah because i've always had
this idea that
you retreat into sort of you have refuge
in the lord
you know and now you're going through
those things and that is what we
that was our practice and that was our
experience and that is where we found
a source of strength in our
relationships with christ
um so
you know having that be a defining
aspect of
any test i fate faced in my life
um yeah it was i i shuddered at the
thought of that
that being gone uh yet here i was
over this past year facing suffering
facing fear
facing loss after having moved on from
that faith
and that's a fear that keeps a lot of
people from
walking away frankly so
i i just want to share three experiences
from this past year
but before i do that i just want to go
ahead and say that
i i'm in a really good place uh
right now spiritually i i don't look
back on on my former life as an
evangelical and
wish that i was still there you know if
you
i think if you go back and listen to my
story there's there's
lots lots of things that you know that i
appreciate and that i value
from from that experience um
it's it's by no means all negative and
i've you know
i already talked about that but i
you know as i go through these these
things i just don't you know i just kind
of want to head off at the past that
like
oh i feel sorry for you and you know i
don't want to
elicit pity because that's not my point
at all i'm going to be very
honest about how i process these things
and
the emotional component and all of that
but i think it's
um the fact that
you know i found a way forward that that
alleviated those those fears that my
former self had
um so yeah i i don't look back and wish
i was there i'm happy
um but i i i am also
restless i don't know if that's exactly
the right word um
because i mean in only a good way uh
but i'm restless in the sense that i'd
like to
think that my spirit or whatever you
want to call it
within myself is staying open
to where i'm headed um even though that
ultimate
destination is unknown
to me uh but i'm doing my best to be
honest with myself
and honest with those that love me and
honest right now
with you listening and i feel hopeful
and uh i'm at peace
with my direction and
today is another day on on that
journey for me and a big component of
that is
it being an active spiritual journey
that that i'm on
and i'm i'm grateful to be doing this
this particular podcast to kind of put
another
um another stake in the ground to say
a year later this is this is how i'm
processing it and this is this is where
i'm
at but it's uh i mean
i'm sure this will get heavy but it's
overall i just wanted to you know i want
to book in it with
um this message that is
is a positive message for me that i'm in
a good i'm in a good place
and i'm glad you're saying that because
you know i think that
you know as you contrast the way that we
approach
these kinds of things right and the way
that we approach our original stories
and the way i'm sure
we're going to approach the sort of the
follow-up
is um you kind of explore things through
your personal experience and story
and you're also you're a verbal
processor
yeah you're um you t
you're you also you know you aren't
quite assure yourself
and that's i mean i don't i think that
that is a that's a positive thing for
you
ultimately i can be a little too
confident and a little too sure in the
things that i'm saying
and a lot of times it'll just piss
people off but sometimes when you're
um being very vulnerable and honest
about
where you're at and the fact that you
know
you're just being honest in in your
uncertainty
i think a lot of people are sort of like
oh
poor link and that's not at all what
you've meant to communicate and right
so i'm glad you're saying that upfront
because i know you and i know
where you're at spiritually and i know
that it's not a place to be pitied
absolutely not that's exactly what i'm
trying to get at and i think that when
you mention
you know my style is is
you know it's it's not as assertive
and maybe when it comes to certain
things i don't assert confidence in
certain things that i believe especially
when what you're what i'm asserting is
embracing uncertainty but i also think
that
a little bit of that well i don't know
how much of it but
there a factor that kind of
drives that in me is kind of reacting to
um i just have a negative reaction to
when people
assert something that i just don't
believe you can know with 100 certainty
it bothers me
yeah um so it's not my instinct to do
that
you know i share my experience
draw draw your own conclusions
or just you know another thing i'm
learning is that you can
you can listen you can truly listen to
somebody you can truly empathize with
somebody
and it's not always about making a
decision or a judgment about them
that was that's something that i've that
i realized that i
i thought for some reason i thought i
had to operate that way and
well that's the that's that's the world
that we come from when you're in a
system
when you encounter things you have to
file them into your system
and so we've kind of been trained for a
lifetime
of systematizing people into an ideology
and we're trying really hard to not
continue to do that there's a way to be
impacted by
empathetically interacting with somebody
that's not
that judgment doesn't have to be a
component of it and
um you know which brings me to the fact
that like
a year later i don't have any more
answers than i had a year ago
but i'll tell you i do believe that my
soul
is richer because i've made some
progress and knowing and loving myself
more that's um through therapy through
introspection through conversations
and i'm beginning to experience
how understanding and accepting myself
has expanded my capacity to love other
people
that's where i felt like i've needed to
focus
a lot of my energy for the past year
in terms of my spiritual journey um
and you know i
i feel like for christy and i as a
couple just to kind of talk about
the two of us for for a little bit um
this this journey is really stretching
uh us and i mean really good stretching
is
really not comfortable you know it's uh
sometimes it hurts a little it needs to
it needs to hurt in the right way
uh so that ultimately
it's it's strengthening and definitely
this
the experiences that that we're going
through together and
um and the spiritual components of that
included um
are strengthening our bond
so we're good on that front too
christy really helped me figure out what
i wanted to say
today and you know i was
as i was kind of prepping it you know i
i texted her yesterday and
uh i sent something to her and i just
also told her how much i love
us uh and she replied and said i love us
too
i want you to feel freedom and embrace
the journey
that you are on heart emoji and it it
meant so much
you know to have her support and to say
be free embrace what you're going
through
you know it's not you're not a victim of
something
you know this is a journey to be
embraced to be celebrated
and uh you know but i'm just so grateful
that
that she can she loves me in that way
and that she can she sent she can send
me that text
you know um i don't think i'd be able to
share these things publicly right now
uh without her support i know i wouldn't
uh and
people also wonder about our kids in
this process so you know i
i want to talk about that just just a
little bit too um
uh honestly i mean
there are times when the fear
creeps back in that maybe we've done
them a disservice
by not raising them in the church
but i don't believe that because
i see them i know their hearts
i mean while there may be things they
missed out on
um there are many pitfalls they were
spared
um and you know i i
i look at lily i look at lincoln i look
at lando and
i know them that you know they're
wholehearted
wonderful humans
and i admire them so much for who they
are
and um
i'm i'm proud of them and
i don't i don't regret the
i don't regret the the trajectory
of our lives and you know
how how we parented them and uh
uh i i i stand by it overall
you know i'm i'm very flawed and but i
think it's important that
that they could articulate those flaws
well you know i think
one of the things that both of us have
encountered
post deconstruction as a dad
is um
within the church within the evangel
evangelical church
there is an expectation that the dad the
father is the spiritual leader of the
household
yeah it's based on a lot of things
mostly just patriarchy but
um and there's an expectation that
not only would the dad be a leader but
the dad has the answers right
right and the dad sets the tone so it's
the pace he leads his family
and i mean he's held
and he's held accountable to that well
but also as a christian
man as a christian dad there's this
uh expectation that you'll have the
answers and that there's very few things
that you
won't have answers to and there is a
playbook for everything that your kids
or your wife might encounter first of
all a lot of pressure
uh but i think in my case there was a
lot of sort of just playing along with
that
being like i don't really have the
answers to this but i can point you to
an answer that we sort of collectively
as a community come up with and i think
one of the biggest things as a father
is when there is true uncertainty there
are
there are situations that do not have an
answer
and being able to say i don't know
i don't know if there's a if there's a
satisfactory answer to this question
that you have
i don't know if there's a satisfactory
solution to this
situation um but we can figure it out
together
and and that's and if you've had
something if you've had a system
and you no longer have the system you
can feel
that fear that you're talking about it's
like man they're going through this
right now and if i just
i'm not sure it's the right answer but
it is an answer that i could be getting
from my former
belief system and now i'm just saying
i don't know and you feel a little bit
you feel like a failure a little bit
yeah i mean lily's
turning 18 she's leaving the house go
off to college
and you know be an adult
but and you know everything i said a few
seconds ago still stands but you know i
i have noticed that there's times when i
would not
i think i would i would opt to not say
something because
it would be you know i would the
instinct is
in the lack of an answer it's it's hard
to make something a teachable moment
when the
when what you're when what you're
conveying
is embracing uncertainty
and the truth of that and it's uh you
know i
i think some things will come true as i
can come clear as i continue talking
about come true too come true
as i you know clear become clear about
you know what i continue to wrestle with
from my past
and how it impacts my point of view
uh myself and my relationships with and
christy and the kids and other other
people but um
you know i i'm tr i'm trying to take a
more active effort
to have conversation open-ended
conversations where
these topics are not taboo just because
you don't have an answer doesn't make it
taboo
it doesn't make it something to be
ashamed of you know it's like this is
this is real
and let's not let's not be afraid to
uh talk about it openly as a family
um so i mean what
just to complete that point when i when
i look at my relationship with myself
my relationship with christy and with
our kids i'm just i am so grateful
for what we have and i'm relieved
honestly because like we said there was
a time for most of my life in fact
um when i firmly believed that those
relationships could not flourish
and whether life storms apart from jesus
um so
i you know i'm
with all that we shared last year and
i i i still struggle with giving myself
permission um to outright say this but
uh if there is no god i'm okay with that
in fact i'm even good with that
that i'm not saying i prefer that but
i'm saying i'm even good with it i i
have accepted that
as a real possibility and
i think i'm at peace with it uh maybe
there's a loving god
and i'm open and hopeful that there is
but i'm also good if i never find out
um because there's just no guarantee
that i will find out
um in the meantime part of my spiritual
practice
is processing and
shedding the guilt and baggage of
judgment that i've carried for the
majority of my life
um maybe my point of view on these
things that i've
stated you know maybe they sound like
harsh
statements i think about you know people
who love me
who would hear me say those things and
i'm like well maybe maybe i could have
taken the edge off of that
and maybe maybe my perspective will
change
over time but um that's where i'm at and
i don't want to be
embarrassed or or ashamed of it or like
i said
i want to shed the guilt and baggage of
judgment that comes along with me
saying that out loud to
who knows how many people um
i mean that's just a big part of my
personal work right now because
i mean at 42 i hopefully have even more
life to live than i've already lived
well so at least 84. yeah i'm aiming for
85.
well that would i mean i don't know i
would that would be a lot more currently
beyond
the average life expectancy of an
american male 1 keep that to yourself
but
i have to believe that that'll keep i i
think it's actually
reversed recently and living in
california and breathing in all this
smog you're probably not doing yourself
i'm just saying you'll be lucky to get
to 84.
well okay given it that it seems that
half of my life is over i'm going to
live the life that i have
uh and i'm going to embrace it
wholeheartedly i you know i want to move
forward embracing the now
that i have been gifted yeah
um and i can say that i've been gifted
even though i don't know
if there's even if there's a giver but i
hope there is
uh so i i i'm ready to share
uh some of my experiences uh
three of them over the past year that
have helped define what my spiritual
journey looks like
um up to this point
um
like i said you know i for me to say
it's been a difficult year i'd you know
i
i can keep acknowledging how how people
have it more difficult or how it's been
a difficult year for so many people but
you know just uh um it has been a long
and difficult year
uh and
there was a there was a a pretty lengthy
build up to
uh my nanny passing away you know i
mentioned that as one of like my
most meaningful moments of last year
um of course that's my mom's
mom and um she had a sense that her life
was winding down
uh so i was the one to help her get her
will
in order and it wasn't just one
conversation
you know it's like the whole process
including getting her to a lawyer and
talking to
everything all everything that went
along with it it's just
a number of months you know and it's
it's all happening over the phone and
you know it's you know
she loved me her whole life
uh and in the end i did i just couldn't
be there
to just hug her uh
and you know it's so much of
our communication was just about you
know me helping her
find peace with this outlying thing
associated with her will
which i i you know i was very glad to do
but it's
you know it's it's i felt frustrated
and i felt helpless and i felt
sad you know it's just uh
you find yourself it's different when
you're just having a phone call and you
find yourself having
it's like oh this is this is the last
phone call
you know i'm i'm saying something
you know to her that it's different
because you're not there
and um and then you're not there for the
family afterward
i mean it's it's it was
it was tough you know uh and
you know of course
i wanted to hope that she was in heaven
uh all of me believes there is no hell
uh but a big part of me believes that
there might not be a heaven either
we just cease to exist um
but i mean that you know it okay
that's that's what i that's i hold that
thought i hold that belief in my mind
but it gets difficult to wrestle with
when you've got one more loved one on
the other side
right
but it didn't change the conclusions
i've already come to you know it's i
i i think of a fear of death
and you know a desire for
eternal life for my loved ones and
myself is
you know is is very appealing but
it's not you know i that's not the
foundation for
what i believe it's a it's a it's
it's like a it's like a benefit i felt
like
um so
so it i don't know although it might be
the foundation for religion in general
just it didn't but i it just didn't
change my conclusions i didn't find
myself as i was
as i was hurting and i was wrestling
with that or i was
you know i was writing her eulogy
to give to somebody else to read and you
know it was
uh all of those feelings
uh it
it it it didn't lead to doubt
honestly it was just of cour you know of
course she's gonna die
of course we're all gonna die it's just
you know it's
um it was it was kind of this
i have these conclusions and i have this
pain and
i'm aware that these things will happen
uh so it's
it i'm left with
i don't know you know do i know can i
assert where she is can i
can i give that comfort can i comfort
myself or
my loved ones in that way i i don't know
who who
really does um
so i celebrated her life as much as i
could and i talked to my family
and processed it as much as i could and
i tried to embrace the grief to make it
as real as possible without being there
and except
something we all know that death is a
part of life and that this
is a a part of my spiritual exercise
um
i couldn't have predicted beforehand
that that's how i would have interacted
with all of it
uh and you know there'll be another way
when i eventually do get to go home
and you know help get everything in
order
that's still around at the house and
stuff i'm sure there'll be another wave
of this but
um well the fact is is that you
again whatever you
can say in a eulogy about your
grandmother that doesn't come from a
place
rooted in christian faith um
is not going to be as emotionally
satisfying
uncertainty is not as emotionally
satisfying as
this certain hope that what you can tell
everybody there
hey she's in a better place like let's
just be honest that is the easiest thing
to say
right that is the easiest most
comforting thing to say
to a group of grieving people is that
this person's in a better place
i do think that they're and you know i'm
i'm still
thinking a lot about this there's uh in
terms of you know my relationship with
death and i do think that there is i i
do
have hope that there's more there is
more
there's a way to embrace it and not shy
away from it
that to find beauty in it that is
different um that's not something that
i'm at a place to present but it's
something that
i guess maybe ironically i'm hopeful
about well i don't think
culturally or as a species were there
yet honestly right
culturally as meaning that the cultural
convention of a
of a of a faith-based funeral is still
the standard even for people who aren't
really
faith-based in a lot of ways right it's
another another conversation um
i guess to to move on to another
experience
i i alluded to this as well at the end
of the year but christy and i walked
through
a really difficult time together over
many months
this past year and
anxiety is not someone's fault
and it affects more than just the one
who's directly experiencing it
it was it was a tough stretch pun
intended
there were many sleepless nights and
there was a lot of fear
um uh there were times when i felt
completely
disoriented and uh
again powerless and uh
scared i mean you know because you and
jesse
were there for us
as well as some other close friends
but throughout all of it uh
i didn't really ever think about praying
now as an aside um
i just want to acknowledge that even now
as i say
that it you know it i think it comes out
like a confession
you know it's like i didn't even think
about praying and
i'm not saying that i wish i did i'm
making an observation
and i want to unpack it but like for a
second i'm unpacking my emotions
associated with even saying it and the
fact that it comes across as a
confession
um
i feel ashamed uh i feel shame
it just it just wells up from inside of
me uh
uh it making that statement
it i like i feel the feelings
of failure or being a bad person
uh
but here's what i believe about that i
believe that
that is my inner critic talking a
version
of my former self
and he is not being
fair or kind
or correct um
if i don't believe in the power of
prayer why should i feel
guilty about not praying
uh and so i
you know i process that and i say come
on just come on link just be free
be free of this and um
i mean if it were only that easy if it
was like encanting
some sort of uh you know a spell or like
a something to release the spell maybe
it's a better analogy
but i mean you know this we talk about
it sometimes we we joke about it which i
think is healthy but i feel guilty a lot
um it's not
really re related
i mean in this instance it's not related
to like
specific nitpicky things like oh i'm i'm
guilty because i did that like this like
an ocd fixation on individual actions
uh you know it's more i think my guilt
comes from this place of like a
lingering cloud
of of guilt that shows up
hangs around and is associated with the
overall idea of me
leaving my faith it's the it's the pity
of my previous self feeling sorry for me
and also judging the the now me
um but i'm learning that
i don't have to listen to that voice
so i can say you know what christy and i
walked through an extremely challenging
period of time
um and
it you know it i didn't pray
it wasn't and it wasn't this stubborn
why you know
i've i've said what i believe and now i
got to believe it and
i'm not going to pray you know there was
no internal dialogue about that
i just i just you weren't tempted you
weren't i wasn't i wasn't wrestling with
reverse doubt or like i didn't
you know like cover my bases like i was
at my wit's
end i mean we were having conversations
that like i would hear what i was saying
to you and it was just
i didn't know what i meant you know i i
haven't observed
i haven't been in that situation before
i don't know that i mean you tell me
have you ever seen
me or christy at a place where it was
like i don't know
it seems like a different person like at
kind of a loss
you were incapacitated right
yeah and you know i think that is a
moment
where you know it cinematically speaking
where the character would drop to their
knees and say
oh god i'm sorry that i
that i've i forsook you plea
you know like a moment of repentance or
something or just
a moment of desperate prayer you know
like you know you have the the cinematic
bargaining
with god you know well and i think
that's because that's
the that's the narrative that we that we
believe and i think
yeah i think it's it'll cut you'll hit
rock bottom and i think that's what a
lot of people have said about us it's
just like okay well those boys are
riding high right now but
you know the moment that the bottom
drops out from one of them some tragedy
happens it's like that's the moment that
they'll
they'll turn around and come back to god
and
are you go and i i just don't i don't
want to skip over the inner voice thing
because i if you're not going to come
back to it because
because i think that's really
significant for so many people the
former voice
and especially as somebody who struggles
with i don't necessarily
i struggle with a lot of shame i'm the
king of shame but guilt is not so much
my thing
but for somebody who has who struggles
with guilt
being a part of a religious system
especially
uh in our experience evangelical
christianity it's like steroids for the
guilty right
uh it's it's high octane and
and i of course i understand that like i
remember being an evangelical and saying
that like listen no we're all about
grace it's the catholics
or the jews they're the ones who are all
about works and they're the ones who are
guilt-ridden but we live in the freedom
that comes with a grace based
relationship with christ
and it's like it's a fun thing to say
but in reality there's still so much
pressure and there's still so much
expectation my wife is an expert at
talking about this
about what it's like to be somebody with
ocd in the midst of a religious system
but one of the things that so i
also do the same thing i have that
former self who's constantly
judging me yeah i think it's one of the
reasons that i
can talk about these things in a way
that connects with people who are still
in the church because i
have a really really strong connection
with my former self
but the change in relationship and this
is something that's come with come
through therapy
my therapist has helped me see this is
that what you're talking about is
looking at that former self and saying
that former self is wrong that former
self
um is being judgmental that former self
is not being kind and i don't have to
listen to that former self
i think one additional step
that has been really helpful for me is
having sympathy yes well i would say for
having empathy empathy having empathy
for that former self well yeah
and absolutely and so i'm i'm glad you
you teed that up because that that is
something that i'm
that i'm working on it's like okay i
know that this
um this inner critic this inner voice
this
former self is is harsh
but i don't i can i don't have to
respond that way because
i can also see that there's uh
uh his his motive is to protect
me it's it's a part of myself
uh yes for my past but it's a part of is
still a part of who i am that's trying
to protect me
from something but it's like okay you
know what i appreciate
what what you're trying to do here and i
i know you're just trying to
help me and and protect me and you know
there is work for me to say okay
protect me from what and let's get into
those specifics but
to have an empathetic response that's
like but you know what
thank you but i don't i don't have to
take action on this and you are not
all of me um so
so yeah that is something that uh in
therapy i'm
i'm i'm seeing i i uh
and i might hit on it a little bit more
with this with this third experience but
yeah you're you're exactly right and i'm
glad you brought that up
um so just to get back to the trial
or however you want to put it like what
christie and i went through and
i mean i i don't want to i
i'm not going to share all the details
of it at this point i think
you know a lot of that's her story to
tell and it's it's or maybe our story to
tell
together at some point who knows but for
now you know i just say that it was
it was a christie was dealing with
a debilitating level of anxiety
uh you know with
with all the circumstances that are
happening i guess a certain level of
health anxiety that then just became
uh yeah it just became debilitating and
there were panic attacks
and there was you know there was uh
it's not as simple as googling how to
deal with a panic attack or how to
how to how to deal with health anxiety
you know it's like you find yourself in
in a place where it's okay the natural
tendency is a downward spiral here
that then we've gotta we gotta start
find the right people to talk to and the
right things to do to put
um to to back back out of this
or to to walk really i would say to walk
through it
yeah to uh to a healthier place
um but
as far as it relates to my spiritual
journey just kind of processing how i
did respond to it
um yeah i i didn't pray to or
curse god um
i just i i mean
i just responded practically you know i
did everything that i could i just
i mean when i look back on it i i would
say that i
met the situation with love
uh i felt as if i was acting on instinct
at the time and
but i realized now that it was i mean it
was simply love uh
i love christy with everything that i've
got
and um and it was
it was then that i i mean i really knew
it at those points
you know uh and we leaned on friends
and professionals to help us
and they did and we got through it
um and i mean
it's not their residual effects and
there's there's some long-term things
that
that we deal with associated with it and
that we're more ready for now but
uh when the worst of it was behind us i
was extremely grateful
um but i didn't thank god
per se um i didn't take credit
i you know i'm
and i'll quiet that voice that tells me
that i should feel guilty for for not
giving god the glory so to speak
[Music]
i mean maybe somebody
would would listen to our description of
that inner voice
and say that that's god or that's the
holy spirit and
you know but i don't i don't know but i
do not think so
you know it's uh because of the
the outcome of of of what that voice is
telling me the application of it it's
just not
that's not it well and
as someone who is also married to
someone who has had a lifelong struggle
with anxiety
in a in a struggle with anxiety that
has been debilitating at times and has
happened
inside the church and you know with with
great faith
and then outside of the church with no
faith in that system
um
there is a in my experience
there is a tendency to
[Music]
because you have the ability to pray
and because you do have the ability to
when you're at your wit's end to sort of
give it over to the lord to invite god
into it
um sometimes that leads to
excluding or bypassing
the practical steps that would actually
be helpful
yeah we had to drill in very deeply and
specifically
with with professionals involved
with therapists and psychiatrists and
things that you know there's no
there's no embarrassment associated with
saying that and
in the same way that if you had a
physical condition if you had
you know that you would you would drill
in medically
and you would do everything you could
and you were just a resort there are
people within the church
only a spiritual exercise there are
people with like church and and
and we want we don't come from a
tradition that is like anti-science and
anti-uh
i mean little anti-science but not like
anti-doctor necessarily i mean it's kind
of becoming more anti-doctor with covet
and everything but
um there is this
there is a little bit of a oh you you
you didn't god didn't do this for you
you kind of had to go to the world
to get your problem solved and there's
some people depending on what tradition
they're in that are
that live in debilitating mental
illness yes because they cannot
specifically out of the system
especially mental illness because
um because those type of things
are the unseen
problems and challenges are the ones
that can be easily written off
with a prayer or a proverb or
you know some teaching and i i
you know having having
benefited from therapists and
psychiatrists
and psychological uh
treatment it it's just not the
you know it it doesn't pinpoint the
the specific problems you know i i think
that it requires a professional to do
that it's not just
something that you can apply just to
general platitude
and i'll admit something that this
probably get me in trouble but i'm used
to it
um now when we seek
treatment from professionals whether
they be
therapists psychologists psychiatrists
either for ourselves or for other people
that we know who are going through
things
um i actually at this point in my life
i try to steer away from people who have
a faith-based approach or who
who really bring
a christian world view into their
treatment
again because my experience is that
it's like filling in the gap with
something that isn't actually going to
be helpful
um it's like like let's set that aside
let's set that uncertain i don't know if
praying does anything
giving it to god may do nothing let's
take the practical
tested approach to this problem uh so we
can
actually solve it and again i'm not
saying that having a christian worldview
is a bad thing i'm just saying when
somebody is
if i've got a cancer doctor who's who's
who's working on me
i don't want that doctor to say you know
what i'm
doing this operation on you but i'm
really praying that it goes well
or i just or do i just want him to say
i'm going to do
it well and i it's all on me to do it
well
again well i don't yeah i'm sure that
there's pastors who if people come to
them
from their congregation with problems
they'll say with this particular
challenge that you're sharing with me
you need to see a
psychiatrist a psychologist a therapist
you know
but that wasn't our experience when we
were growing up and you wouldn't even
even if you had to go to one of those
places you would just use you would say
i went to counseling you would use a
code word and
it would be stigmatized and there's like
a lot of prayer based counseling and
that kind of thing
that yeah that's it that's acceptable
you can do that
but if it's just the practical
scientific stuff then
i don't know about that that's kind of
the attitude that that we had
um so the i'll move to the third
and final experience that uh i wanted to
share today and that's
um
and there's yeah the the details of this
are
are are are not my story to tell so
you know forgive me for but don't
forgive me just on i know you
understand that the way that i'm i'm
telling this and the details i'm putting
in and leaving out but
um my mom is
currently facing what may be the most
difficult
trial of her entire life
every day all year long
for years now um
and again we have the coveted
of it all uh i'm i'm her only child
i don't know if if if you could tell i
was an only child
uh and yeah
and i've not been able to be with her
um and i try my best to get better at
talking on the phone
and to understand her situation and
assess what needs to be done
and to help her and uh but i'm stuck on
the opposite coast
because of the pandemic and so i
you know i worry about her and um again
it's that
that feeling of helplessness
and um you know i i feel bad for going
weeks in between talking to her
and uh
but when i do talk to her
she's always happy to hear my voice uh
and she doesn't want to dump her
problems on me
but what else is there to talk about
because this has become her entire life
you know so so we talk about how she's
doing
and um i try to really hear her
and offer encouragement and help
think through things um
and it's it's it's become you know
you know like i i just realized how
difficult and the toll this was also
taking on me
you know uh and
we were we're on the phone recently and
uh
she relayed a conversation that she
had with someone else and um
i'm not going to tell you the story
because the story uh
was meant for me and you know when she
told me
the conversation she had uh she didn't
build it up
or maybe she didn't even realize the
poignancy of it
uh but
again i'm not sure i don't want to share
her situation but
what she shared was it was heartbreaking
and it was
honest and it was uh
beautiful and it was tragic and it was
inspiring
and it stopped me dead in my tracks
and in in this moment i realized
um not only was i being there for my mom
but even with all that she was going
through
she was also still being there for me
um and the specifics of
her her story
um and what she was
what she went through and was telling me
about
it painted this perfect picture of love
um and
she showed me a type of love to aspire
to
uh and i've you know i've thought a lot
about it since then and
i i've realized um
that this is my spiritual practice
uh
love will be my guide
uh i'm gonna you know i'm gonna make up
my mind to be introspective
uh to not miss moments like that
as much as i can and i
i will not tear myself apart from the
inside
i will love myself and i will love
others
as much as i can and i will live the
life that i have
and
you know that's my spiritual practice
at a point where and so it
i don't know i you know i don't know how
people will process that as glib
or elegant or you know
whatever but for me you know it's
when you boil something down to
something like that
it's there's so much that i just can't
convey that it actually means to me
in terms of uh
i think part of it is validating that
i still have a spiritual i'm still on a
spiritual journey i you know it's not
i'm not defined by what i'm not anymore
um i i'm alive
i'm you know i've got
and i've got this moment we're sharing
this moment and there's so much
there's so much beauty that that we can
enjoy and appreciate or we can miss
and and i'm sure that includes
everything that i've talked about like i
didn't talk about these things to pull
at heartstrings and
just uh to prove anything it was
these things are going to happen who am
i'm not you know
tragedy suffering loss death these are
not things that i want to
try my best to avoid you know who who am
i to expect
for these things not to happen to me and
people that i love
things happen um
and giving my giving myself
permission to say you know what this is
my this is
this is not only my life but this is my
spiritual practice
and
i'm good with it i'm
i i have a i have a level of peace at
this point
and i have and i'm moving forward
hopefully well and it love being
your guide as you know
sixties peace and love as it sounds um
it is actually very
practical and actually
a lot more informative than i would have
ever thought
you know i i because i i just yeah
totally on this because i
thought it couldn't be enough it's like
yeah you i mean you say it can be enough
but
to t to navigate a situation
um a life situation that ha is a very
specific
challenge kind of like the ones that
you've shared here
um there is sort of the
the christian way to do those things
right um
i would argue that in many ways
the christian way is a way of love right
you will not you will navigate it in a
way of love
you can there's you know it's not a
super simple thing
there's plenty of places where everyone
in within the church and outside of the
church fails
in that but holding what i'm saying is
that
going into a complex life situation
where you don't have the rule book the
literal
rule book of the bible to guide you
and saying i'm gonna let love guide me
through this
i think it's actually really really
effective and informative than i would
have ever
imagined it being that's what and i'm
saying that's what
that's what i that's what i'm taking
from these experiences
yeah i mean that that's my takeaway is
that
like it just
you know we i'm still here
this is not about me um
i mean we we normally end in your
biscuit with a recommendation i'm you
know i'm not gonna i'm not
i'm gonna instead of telling you
something to buy or watch
this this this week you know i just
wanted to acknowledge that
um another thing that's very clear to me
and as i look back on these experiences
that i could not have made it through
any of those without the support of
people who loved me my friends my family
um
and so i mean maybe it's
as a result of a spiritual struggle
maybe it's a result of some other
struggle
but if you know i just want to encourage
you if you need help find someone you
trust
someone who loves you no matter what and
if it feels like a risk
take the risk and ask for help
you know i
i know that it really needs to be
somebody that
that you trust who loves you no matter
what and uh
we were talking about like do we have a
specific i wish we had a resource that
would connect
everybody with somebody who loves them
unconditionally and i think that's just
that's how i feel about it but and we
will we will recommend
we will do some research on that what
i'll add to that
is that i know that there are people
listening who are still in
the church or a religious system of some
kind
and um not all listen again the point of
what we what we are telling our stories
is not to move people
out of the of the church
um but there are some people in a
situation
and you know that it is unhealthy and
you know
that you shouldn't be there but you're
alone
and you know that if you go talk to
anybody in your family
anybody who's a close friend they're all
in this they're all in it
yeah and you know the kind of answers
you're gonna get and you feel
you feel stuck you feel alone uh that is
a
that's you know me and link we had each
other
we had our wives we had close friends
we actually had you know had close
christian friends who were not
judgmental and we can process
and we could talk openly about these
things as we processed all of it
you may not have that um
but so first of all just our hearts go
out to you because we know that there
are people in that situation
what we can say is that there is
somebody out there
there is somebody out there that you can
connect with that you can confide in
um and don't give up
don't don't give up the search don't
give up the search
and don't settle for being in a place
that you know
is ultimately unhealthy for you
thanks for listening um i'm so grateful
that we have this
open-hearted community of of support
and uh
lots of love right back at you hashtag
your biscuits
let's keep talking to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best